What would be more general is to have the transparent filter's color affect the
color behind it. In other words, we want to blend the two colors. In blending in
computer graphics, the original color is called the "destination" and the color of
the transparent object we're looking through is called the "source" color. We'd
also like to control how much can be seen through this filter. In computer
graphics this control value is called "alpha". Here it represents our filter's
opacity. When alpha is one, the filter is fully opaque and does not let any
light through. As this value decreases, more of the destination color becomes
visible. Here I'm just showing how the red is affected; the blue would show
through. When alpha is zero, our filter is entirely transparent and has no
effect. A typical way to blend these colors is by using this equation. Here, the
color of the source of our filter is multiplied by the source's alpha. This
gives how much the source will affect the final color. The larger alpha is, the
more the source color affects the final color. To counterbalance this, this same
alpha is subtracted from one, and this value determines how much the destination
color influences the result. This type of blend is called an "over" operator, as
it gives the effect of putting one color over another. The alpha of the source,
our transparent filter, can be any value from zero to one. If the value is zero,
this equation simply becomes "C" is equal to the destination color, since the
source filter is entirely transparent. If the value of alpha is one, the source
is fully opaque and hides what ever it's being placed over. The equation
simplifies as expected, with the final color being the same as the source color.
The alpha value blends between these two colors. Another way to say it is that
the equation performs linear interpolation. As one color's influence increases,
the other color's effect drops off in proportion. This idea of having a control
value, in this case, alpha, that varies between zero and one is commonly used in
many areas of computer graphics. Expect to see this sort of equation elsewhere
as you explore the field. The over operator is useful for transparency. However
there are many other blend modes available on WebGL. For example, one blend mode
is called "add" as it adds the source and destination colors together. In three.js the
blend mode used is specified with the material's blending parameter. Here we see
the over equation in action. By varying the alpha, we fade the effect of the
transparent object on and off. Try it yourself.